I've been talking to parents here at
thurrock this morning and they said they
want their general election because
they're paying the price for the
government having crashed the economy
and we were not even talking about cuts
a month ago the whole discussion about
Cuts has become an issue only because
the government has crashed the economy
what I want to do is to build the
economy to grow the economy and
recognize that it's working people who
grow it so want to stabilize the economy
want to grow the economy we're only
talking about Cuts because this
government crashed the economy and let's
talk about cop would you advise the king
now to go to cop well look it's up to
the king what Pete does but uh the Prime
Minister should be going to cop he needs
to show leadership this is a hugely
important issue climate change is wound
together with the energy crisis and I
think many people would be expecting the
prime minister of the UK not just to
attend cop but to use it as an
opportunity to pull world leaders
together to deal with climate and to
deal with energy and if that doesn't
happen it's a failure of leadership if I
was prime minister I would be going I
would be convening of pulling people
together and sorting out the issues that
are confronting people talking to people
this morning who can't pay their energy
bills they expect their prime minister
to be on the world stage sorting these
problems out it's an absolute failure of
leadership
it's looking like it's one of brave men
you know we live in a country which we
like to think we give people Second
Chances when they've made mistakes she's
got the support of Mark Riley the Met
chief police officer she's got the sport
of Security Services why shouldn't
celebrate the men in a country like ours
be given a second chance this whole
episode
shows us just how weak the prime
minister is
I think he's done a grubby deal trading
security for support so he didn't have
to go through a full election to become
Prime Minister and leader of his party
and it really matters I've been the
director of public prosecution I know
how important it is for the Home
Secretary to be trusted because others
have to share documents with her and to
be sacked last week for a breach of
security and now be put back in place as
the Home Secretary it's an act of
weakness from the Prime Minister he
should sucker that would be the strong
thing to do that's what I would do if I
was prime minister hey can I put more
questions first of all just on Northern
Ireland looks like we're gonna have
elections there it before Christmas
isn't it your assessment that what's
more important to you is that we get
storm and back up and running again that
means the UK taking unilateral action on
the protocol to get the dup back into
government that's the right thing to do
by the people of Northern Ireland we do
need to get the institutions in Northern
Ireland back up and running and the
sooner we can do that the better that
requires our government get people
around the negotiating table and to
resolve the issues on the protocol I
think they can be resolved I think there
are amendments that can be made to the
protocol without ripping it up but the
government needs to get people around
the table and get that agreement because
at the moment we've got a very difficult
situation for people in Northern Ireland
who are suffering as a as a result of
the government's failure to convene this